[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 12 octobre bienvenue dans
le journal de tv 78 tout de suite les
titres
jusqu'à dimanche montigny le bretonneux
organise sa 18e semaine du handicap au
programme ateliers de sensibilisation
expositions et spectacles rencontres
dans cette édition avec les endiablé une
équipe de hand fauteuil qui prépare son
tournoi qui est shanab est maire adjoint
de la commune serait également notre
invité
une plongée dans le riche bestiaire de
l'ancien régime l'exposition les animaux
du roi s'est ouverte aujourd'hui au
château de versailles c'est jusqu'au 13
février environ 300 oeuvres ont été
rassemblés pour l'occasion
et puis les français en consomment
chaque année 819 millions rien que ça la
pizza son événement à paris avec parizza
ce mercredi et jeudi au menu du salon
notamment le championnat de france et un
yvelinois angelo prix viterra sera en
lice pour ce concours il aura à coeur de
mettre en avant une pizza bio et local
mais avant de développer ces titres une
mission gouvernementale sur l'insertion
des jeunes des quartiers par le sport
elle a été confiée par le ministère de
la cohésion des territoires et le
ministère des sports au maire de poissy
karl olive l'élu yvelinois également
administrateur de la ligue de football
professionnel a trois mois pour faire
des propositions en la matière il compte
faire le tour des régions en passant par
les départements d'outre-mer pour
réaliser des auditions remise du rapport
prévue au 11 janvier prochain
[Musique]
18e édition pour la semaine du handicap
à montigny le bretonneux la municipalité
propose des actions de sensibilisation
et différentes animations comme des
expositions des spectacles ou encore des
ateliers ce temps fort a pour objectif
de mettre de côté les différences et de
dépasser le handicap et on en parle avec
mon invité qui est chanabé bonfort
la maire-adjointe de
montigny-le-bretonneux en charge à deux
l'action sociale du handicap et des
seniors alors avant de parler de cet
événement la semaine du handicap vous
propose est de faire la connaissance des
endiablé c'est une équipe de hand
fauteuil de la smb handball et qui se
prépare pour son traditionnel tournoi
qui est au programme samedi et un
tournoi inquiet dans le cadre aussi de
cette semaine du handicap le reportage
de céline charles et de nicolas landry
depuis 13 ans il existe une équipe en
defence au sein du club de handball de
montigny les endiablé le club possède
ses propres fauteuil dans tout le monde
dispose une équipe
composée à la fois 2e en 10 et de
valides d'accord donc c'est important
dans le jeu c'est con et mélanger
ensemble c'est par les handis d'un côté
ce ne sont pas les valides de l'autre
sur le terrain tout le monde est en
fauteuil j'aimais bien l'idée de là
du mélange de la mixité c'est à dire
hommes femmes toutes tranches d'âge
handicap et valides la direction pour
nous est plus compliqué que pour eux ils
vont à 2000 à l'heure où des formes
l'impression que c'est des tempêtes qui
passent et nous on pousse on pousse on
pousse au total c'est une quinzaine de
personnes qui s'entraînent régulièrement
une discipline de plus en plus connue
qui n'est pourtant pas encore porté aux
jeux paralympiques le malheureusement le
handball n'est pas sport paralympique
contrairement contrairement au basket ou
au rugby on a vu prendre le sport
prendre une place beaucoup plus
importante au fur et à mesure des années
les pratiques sont de plus en plus
diversifiée il ya maintenant possibilité
de faire du handi en escrime en tir à
l'arc en tennis de table
enfin dans plein plein plein de
disciplines une occasion malgré tout de
dépasser le handicap est de montrer que
sur le terrain il n'y a aucune
différence que ya une vie après le
handicap et ben ils s'amusent comme nous
ils sont intégrés comme nous voilà donc
je pense que c'est une vraie vraie
réussite et un vrai moment de
décompression comme nous je pense que
quand on joue tous ensemble dans
l'équipe on sait pas qui est qui
handicapée qui est valide c'est juste
une équipe de hand qui joue qui jouent
ensemble et qui partagent un bon moment
sans davantage durant deux fauteuils
c'est que tout le monde peut participer
conçoit valides et non valides tout le
monde joue en fauteuil et ça équilibre
tout le 10e tournoi national de hand
fauteuil se déroulera ce samedi 16
octobre au centre sportif pierre de
coubertin
et c'est au mois et qui sera donc l'un
des temps forts de cette semaine dix
huitième semaine du handicap à montigny
le bretonneux pourra parler je vous
rappelle qu'il ya kachan à b avec moi
maire-adjointe en charge de l'action
sociale du handicap et des seniors
petite réaction des jacques etienne à bo
au sujet que l'on vient de voir ses
endiablé sont parmi les fiers
représentants du handisport du handicap
en général dans cette ville de montigny
et moi je suis je suis très heureuse que
vous ayez pu les rencontrer et votre
reportage et illustre vraiment l'état
d'esprit de cette semaine du handicap
car il s'agit à la fois de
sensibilisation et d'inclusion et là
comme vous le voyez il ya un poids de
l'inclusion et aussi de la mixité donc
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important au niveau de la digne d'amont
thing essaie de montrer aussi j'imagine
tout le tissu associatif est un tissu
associatif qui est unie derrière cet
événement à l'image de saison diablesse
n'y a que là c'est la 18ème édition et
je suis ravi qu'il ait une telle
fidélité de toutes les associations et
de tous nos partenaires aussi
institutionnels qui répondent
systématiquement présent bon alors en
fonction et bien évidemment des
restrictions au niveau des conditions
sanitaires il y à il ya plus ou moins de
facilité mais néanmoins ils sont
toujours présents pour animer les
ateliers et donc participer à ces à ces
compétitions à la fois de en fauteuil on
aura aussi cette année une compétition
de bocchia voilà on innove aussi en
terme d'animation et effectivement il ya
un maillage associatif et
partenariale qui est acquis importants
et qui est nécessaire pour faire vivre
cet événement on va présenter
l'essentiel du programme dans un instant
je le disais 18e édition c'est une
semaine du handicap qui en est
finalement à sa majorité à montigny le
bretonneux que représente-t-elle cette
semaine pour la ville que représente
l'événement pour la ville de montigny le
bretonneux alors oui vous l'avez dit 18
ans c'est l'âge de la maturité
effectivement alors il faut remonter
d'un point de vue historique un tout
autre au début c'était une affaire de
sensibilisation pour permettre aux uns
et aux autres de comprendre ce qu'est le
handicap
et un fait revivre aussi les uns avec
les autres tisser ce lien qui malgré les
années et difficile à mettre en place et
donc là au fil au fil des années on est
aussi dans une dynamique d'inclusion
avec une politique globale au niveau de
la ville avec beaucoup de transversalité
avec les différents secteurs notamment
le scolaire ou en place de nouvelles le
scolaire le périscolaire où on est en
place d'une nouvelle structure pour
accueillir des enfants en situation de
handicap
donc un attachement particulier à faire
vivre tous les éléments d'un ensemble et
donc 18 ans comme vous l'avez dit
l'année certainement de la maturité mais
aussi du changement puisque l'idée est
pour le futur de faire en sorte que le
handicap soit un élément on en dira
fédérateur pour toutes les activités de
la ville à montigny avec l'idée aussi on
imagine de changer les regards vous
parliez tout à l'heure d'inclusion on
voit la fiche de l'événement juste
derrière vous une affiche qui sait aussi
qui a été montré si on peut leur montrer
en régie à cette affiche de ce 18e
rendez vous de la semaine du handicap
avec ce message voilà la majorité de mes
amis aiment ma robe et vous il ya l'idée
de changer les regards on voit une
personne en situation de handicap on va
parler d'abord de sa robe pas de sa
situation d'handicap y est il ya une
idée derrière de changer les regards
tout à fait l'idée de changer le regard
de deux voilà de permettre aux uns et
aux autres de mieux se comprendre
effectivement la fiche je la trouve
magnifique elle est un petit peu
dérangeante parce qu'au départ voilà il
n'est pas bon ne comprend pas
directement ce qu'il en est mais
néanmoins c'est vraiment un esprit de
notre démarche changer le regard permet
de l'inclusion fait en sorte dans tous
les secteurs de la ville le handicap
soit pris en compte et pour n'est
l'accessibilité
à tous les tous les services toutes les
animations aux personnes en situation de
handicap et vous parlez de toutes ces
animations qui concerne
essentiellement les jeunes pas que mais
il ya eu un gros temps fort en dire de
la semaine qui est dédié aux jeunes ces
ateliers de sensibilisation auprès des
scolaires des collégiens des lycéens
changer les regards ça passe forcément
par ses actions de sensibilisation
auprès des jeunes qui finalement seront
les adultes de demain
et bien sûr la sensibilisation commence
très tôt donc nous avons plein
d'ateliers qui permettent aux enfants de
nos deux de nos établissements scolaires
pas seulement les enfants on a on a
aussi des lycéens qui sont déjà de
jeunes adultes pour leur permettre de
voir ce qu'est le handicap sous le
prisme de la difficulté aussi au
quotidien donc c'est c'est important de
pouvoir sensibiliser et donc ces
ateliers sont ouverts aux jeunes et aux
moins jeunes aussi pour le dimanche le
samedi le dimanche avec plusieurs
animations
concernant le braille par exemple où les
différentes challenge que nous au bout
si tu
voulais venir justement en dix ans déjà
qu'il y aussi une journée dédiée au jeu
ce sera mercredi jouons ensemble à la
ludothèque de montigny-le-bretonneux
dont pourrait aussi avoir un côté
ludique effectivement cette journée est
très important de ce forum andy rekrute
mans qui est programmé aussi vendredi on
en revient ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure transversalité on parle de
toutes les thématiques qui concerne le
handicap là pour le coup c'est la
thématique du chômage pour les personnes
en situation de handicap pourquoi oui
organisée au 6e forum profité de cet
événement pour parler de cette
thématique également
aimé justement dans cette semaine du
handicap vous avez tous tous les sujets
sont pris en compte vous avez à la fois
du sport du désensibilisation autre que
le niveau du sport et du recrutement et
on est une des rares villes à prendre en
compte toutes les thématiques concernant
le handicap
donc c'est quelque chose qui était
important voilà et vous avez aussi je
sais pas si vous allez l'évoquer mais on
a un spectacle cette année qui
est en langue des signes
c'est un spectacle qui à destination à
la fois du périscolaire et en soirée il
sera ouvert à tous donc c'est un
spectacle et interactif qui permettra
aux habitants de se familiariser avec la
langue des signes est donc ce spectacle
les inimités à venir s'inscrire et même
au delà des minimums 1 parce que c'est
le handicap l affaire de tous aussi mais
on trouve tout programme sur le site
internet de montigny-le-bretonneux avec
donc vous le disiez ce spectacle
programme demain mercredi mercredi 13
octobre avec une ouverture à tous un à
19h30 et ça se déroule à la salle
jacques-brel de montigny vous avez parlé
du forum andy recrutement je précise
aussi que donc c'est vendredi de 9h à
12h et c'est à l'hôtel de ville c'est en
partenariat avec pôle emploi et cap
emploi et enfin on termine sur le
week-end festif on peut dire il y aura
ce sera au centre sportif pierre de
coubertin avec des ateliers de
sensibilisation et le dimanche il ya le
défi de l'espérance c'est un défi
classique pour cette semaine du handicap
où on se met en dans la situation d'une
personne en situation de handicap ces
défis les yeux bandés c'est ça c'est ça
tout à fait donc c'est organisé par le
média handicapant donc qui est une
association qui est fidèle depuis de
nombreuses années on aura de nombreux
défis en fauteuil roulant ou en
les yeux bandés pour se mettre en
situation de handicap voilà le programme
de la semaine du handicap à retrouver
bien sûr sur le site internet de
montigny le bretonneux merci qui est
chanabé d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous
je rappelle maire-adjointe de montigny
le bretonneux en charge de l'action
sociale du handicap et des seniors
[Musique]
et si vous alliez à la rencontre des
animaux du roi jusqu'au 13 février le
château de versailles accueille cette
exposition de plus de 300 oeuvres toutes
ont un lien avec les animaux qui ont
vécu dans la bâtisse royal des
appartements au château à la mennais la
la ménagerie en passant par le gibier
présent également dans le parc forestier
découverte avec nicolas landry
voici l'animal préféré du roi louis xiv
la poule sultane un animal domestique
présent au château de versailles une des
nombreuses curiosités à découvrir durant
l'exposition les animaux du roi du 12
octobre au 13 février 2022 toute la
faune présente au coeur de la cité
royale sur différentes générations de
louis xiv louis saez en passant par
louis 15 on sent qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose d'assez important dans la
conception des animaux de leur personne
le respect l'attachement aux animaux
véritable arche de noé version ancien
régime cette exposition propose 300
oeuvres une rencontre avec les animaux
qui ont participé à la vie du château de
versailles à commencer par cette
éléphante naturalisés de louie 15 une
réalité de l'époque à la ménagerie
royale construite entre 1662 et 1664
aujourd'hui détruite l'idée de 2 du roi
c'était d'avoir une ménagerie qui
montrerait toutes les espèces les plus
curieuses de la terre on avait
évidemment les animaux les plus
extravagants ours enfin tout ce qu'on
pouvait réunir dans la ménagerie était
présent et il ya eu des scènes fameuse
de dissection d'études de ces animaux
puisque le l'esprit était très
scientifique pendant tout l'ancien
régime le lien avec l'animal c'est aussi
lors d'une activité traditionnelle du
roi la chasse à courre
[Musique]
la façon de gérer les mails émeutes et
les chiens de chasse que ce soit de la
chasse à tir où la chasse à courre est
par exemple le fait de donner des noms à
tous les chiens de chasse qui est une
nouveauté sous louis 15 en fait on ne
les voit pas comme de simples outils qui
servent à poursuivre le gibier ce sont
des compagnons en fait dans l'exercice
de ce loisir royal à plumes ou à poils
les animaux sont aussi des symboles
politiques
un moyen pour le roi de représenter son
pouvoir absolu
du côté de rambouillet le château la
bergerie nationale et le palais du roi
de rome ont fêté le bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon 1er une reconstitution
grandeur nature et de la vie pendant l'
empire qui était proposé le week-end
dernier avec exposition saynètes et
représentation militaire à l'honneur
retour avec céline soral et mélanie
poker
ils sont des centaines à venir des
quatre coins de la france et de la
belgique c'est reconstitueurs passionnés
d'histoire qui confectionnent leurs
costumes eux mêmes sont venus redonner
vie à l'époque impériale au château nous
invitons des associations de
reconstitueurs qui reconstitue une
journée à la cour impériale au château
de rambouillet et qui est ponctué de
deux saynètes et de périodes de
divertissement assuré par des comédiens
des musiciens et des danseurs ont fait
cette année l'année 2000 21 l'année
napoléon c'est le bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon qui est mort donc le 5
mai 1821
vous pouvez voir un campement militaire
donc un bivouac avec de l'infanterie
vous avez également de la cavalerie une
musique mais également tout un village
civil populaire reconstituer jeux
d'époque dance music ou encore mode le
parcours des animations retrace la vie
publique mais aussi intime de napoléon
qui au total a séjourné 60 jours au
château de rambouillet c'est grâce à
cette venue où il s'est dit mais là il
ya vraiment quelque chose à remettre en
branle à remettre en marche donc il a il
a fait
réaliser des travaux au niveau du
château est également la bergerie le but
c'était vraiment redynamiser l'artisanat
français à travers la laine un événement
qui rappelle aussi le passé historique
riche du château qu'est ce qu'on a comme
chance à rambouillet d'avoir le bonheur
de ce château et de l'histoire qu'il
porte j'ai le souvenir personnel dit
avoir partagé un moment avec un
président de la république je leur
racontais françois mitterrand
je venais d'être élu maire de
rambouillet un autre moment avec un
premier ministre d'avoir accueilli
vladimir poutine et puis un endroit où
la gardien nous rendre les honneurs nous
avions le président mordez là les 35 ans
du jumelage entre rambouillet et water
blue était également célébré ce week-end
avec la présence d'une délégation
officielle
au chapitre sport les coureurs du
dimanche avait rendez vous le 10 octobre
pour la ville proviennent l'événement
running organisé par la commune de
villepreux au programme quatre parcours
de 1 et 2 km pour les enfants 5 et 10 km
pour les adultes plus de 400 personnes y
ont participé une course qui est passé
par les rues de la ville et qui se veut
familial écouter ses propos recueillis
par patrick jacques de dixmude c'est le
plaisir de courir sur ville preuve c'est
le plaisir de courir en famille
l'avantagé d'avoir les quatre distances
c'est que ça permet vraiment à toute la
famille de pouvoir participer à la
course et pour la première fois cette
année l'événement avait une vocation
solidaire a notamment savoir de
l'association dunes d'espoir une
joëlette a pris le départ du 10 km avec
à son bord un enfant handicapé et puis
pour chaque inscription la ville
proviennent reversait un euro à
l'association valentin haüy qui
accompagne les personnes aveugles et
malvoyants les bénévoles étaient
présents pour faire découvrir notamment
une carte de france en relief 700 euros
ont pu être reversés à l'association
assez importante pour pour nous en fait
qui nous permettent d'organiser des
activités notamment
voilà pour cet événement la ville
proviennent qui s'est déroulée dimanche
dernier à villepreux avec en moyenne 10
kg de pizzas consommés par an et par
habitant les français se place dans le
trio de tête des plus gros mangeur
derrière les états unis mais devant
l'italie 7 à noter la pizza qui ya son
rendez vous à paris parizza qui se
déroule ce mercredi et jeudi au parc des
expositions de la porte de versailles un
rendez vous avec notamment au menu le
championnat de france de la pizza cette
année un yvelinois y participent ils
s'appellent angelo prix viterra avant de
refermer ce journal nous sommes allés le
rencontrer avec gabriel gonthier et
bixente magnin santisteva je vais donc
vous confectionnez devant vous ici une
pizza au feu de bois allez c'est parti
angelo prix viterra et depuis 2010 est
le dirigeant de la société bio pizza un
nom qui en dit long sur ses intentions
ma conviction c'est de travailler en
circuit court de façon à promouvoir un
certain nombre de métiers qui regroupe
justement que ce soit des agriculteurs
que ce soit des fromagers alors là je
vous prépare une pizza une régie n'a
tout simplement si une pizza avec ne la
mozza du jambon
on y va et des champignons des recettes
bio et local qui ont entraîné angelo à
s'inscrire au championnat de france de
la pizza je me suis inscrit tout
simplement parce que c'est un petit défi
personnel je me suis dit pourquoi pas
aussi
me faire connaître de cette façon là et
faire connaître aussi mes pizzas tout
simplement puisque voilà j'aimais
beaucoup de coeur et de passion pour
l'événement qui se déroulera les 13 et
14 octobre avec environ 130 participants
le pizzaïolo ne compte pas déroger à ses
principes absolument en tête en tout cas
les grandes lignes parce qu'après il
faut toujours travailler sur une recette
par définition chez plutôt
perfectionniste donc voilà j'essaie de
travailler les goûts et les saveurs les
mariages l'alchimie parce qu'une pizza
c'est aussi la cheminée chimie des
saveurs mais toujours en tenant compte
de produits de saison locaux pour ce
faire il pourra aussi compter sur la
recette de sa pâte faite maison dont il
tient à garder le secret et voilà la
[Musique]
bonne chance à angelo que vous pouvez
retrouver tous les midis du mardi au
vendredi sur le parking de l'hôtel
formule 1 aux mureaux les mercredis soir
du côté de la mairie & daigremont les
jeudis soir près du poste de police de
chambourcy les vendredis et samedis
soirs sur le domaine de mars aval à
chambourcy et enfin les samedis midi à
orgeval du côté de la zone commerciale
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]